[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de retour depuis l'université des mères
avec bruno myle yens
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député modem
de la 9e circonscription des yvelines
il va parler avec vous on va essayer d'y
voir plus clair un peu dans ce problème
des finances locales parlent beaucoup de
taxe d'habitation évidemment on vient y
redire
peut-être dans ce site contexte de
retrait d'économies sur les dépenses
publiques qui sont nécessaires et auquel
peut-être les gens ne comprennent pas
grand chose donc on va essayer
d'expliquer un petit peu d'abord la taxe
d'habitation donc c'était une promesse
de du candidat macro qui a été tenue 80
% d'ici 2022 c'est ça or le dernier
paiement de la taxe d'habitation
interviendra pour l'année 2022 en 2023
plus personne manquante nouvelle 1,3
plus personne ne paiera de taxe
d'habitation donc ça sera égalisé pour
tout le monde
en quoi c'était une mesure importante ça
de supprimer la taxe d'habitation la
taxe d'habitation alors après on peut
être d'accord ou pas avec cette théorie
bien évidemment moi je n'ai pas de souci
là-dessus mais la taxe d'habitation pour
nous c'était le l'impôt le plus injuste
pour les français en terme de pouvoir
d'achat
pensez par exemple que dans certaines
communes rurales des yvelines on paye à
surface égale plus de taxe d'habitation
que quelqu'un qui habite le 7e
arrondissement de paris il ya comme une
espèce de truc complètement aberrant
donc on a décidé tout simplement la
supprimer parce que c'est un impôt qui
n'est pas lisible pour les citoyens et
qui est surtout excessivement injuste
pas du tout équitable
donc après effectivement une fois qu'on
a dit ça il faut qu'on compense pas ce
que c'est parce que c'était quand même
une ressource pour les gamers pour les
colis bien sûr puisqu'elle avait elle
avait il avait le choix justement de
lever l'impôt et d'augmenter ou de
baisser les pourcentages la taxe
d'habitation le choix qui a été fait
c'est de dire qu'on va prendre la taxe
foncière la part de la taxe foncière du
département et on va là redistribué aux
communes
on va pas simplement lever de l'argent
département on va dire donner de
l'argent via la tva donc bien la misère
à tous est une compensation compensation
à l'euro près c'est là dessus qu'on
s'était engagé sans créer de nouvel
impôt
ce qui est important de savoir notamment
pour les communes on va dire les petites
communes c'est que le fait de donner la
taxe foncière aux communes va provoquer
des sueurs ou des sous compensation pour
les communes celles qui seront sur
compensation jusqu'à 10000 euros
je pense que le seuil va être aux
alentours de là il n'est pas défini
parce qu'on va en discuter la discussion
du projet de loi
j'adore le tour de là on leur laissera
les 10000 euros ce sera dix mille euros
supplémentaires pour et celles qui sont
sous compenser on perd à la sous
compensation à l'euro près on a estimé
ça à peu près un milliard d'euros pour
que effectivement toutes les communes
retrouve exactement les mêmes bases de
recettes qu'elle avait avec la taxe
d'habitation donc l'engagement c'est pas
de perte de recettes aux veaux pour
l'économie verte de recettes alors après
évidemment les maires à juste titre nous
disent oui mais alors on n'a plus aucun
lien finalement fiscale avec nos
administrés il n'y a plus aucun lien
entre administrés le maire m'a sauf que
comme on leur donne la part de la taxe
foncière
il peut rejouer dessus sur le taux donc
le lien reste de toute façon entre les
administrés et les élus de la
municipalité tout s'inscrivant dans un
contexte qui est générale qui touche
l'état qui touche
on le voit avec beaucoup de
manifestations qui touchent les communes
qui touchent le département qui est la
nécessaire politique d'économie des
dépenses publiques ça va avec ça vous
avez alors les choses ne viennent jamais
par hasard patrice vous savez très bien
ça fait depuis que maps tam nôtres ont
été votés qu'on demande effectivement
aux intercommunalités aux collectivités
en général de réduire la voilure sur
leurs dépouilles
on se souvient que le précédent
gouvernement avait baissé
considérablement les dotations globales
de fonctionnement wyss avait commencé
sous il avait baissé l'argent même que
l'état donné depuis qu'on est arrivé en
2017 on est resté sur le dernier
tôt et on a laissé ce taux là il n'y a
pas de baisse de la dgf depuis 2017 et
cette année il y aura même un milliard
d'euros de plus pour l'investissement
qui sera donnée aux collectivités
en échange de quoi on a quand même
demandé aux collectivités d'être un
petit peu plus alors d'être un petit peu
plus sérieuse ça veut rien dire mais en
tout cas de faire attention aux deniers
aux deniers publics et donc et donc on
n'a pas cessé contractualisation qui
sont la partie fonctionnement encore une
fois sur la partie font de ce groupe en
recadre un petit peu les choses en leur
demandant de ne pas dépasser de plus de
plus 1,2 pour cent les dépenses de
fonctionnement
année après année pratiquement toutes
les collectivités ont signé et on peut
dire que le taux de retour est assez
impressionnant puisque tout quasiment
sont restés dans les +1 2% et même
certaines ont été en dessous même en
dessous de 1% d'augmentation donc
c'était faisable
ça mérite peut-être une petite
explication c'est que quand ces
intercommunalités se sont créés comme
une ombre et des transferts de
compétences etc
la mutualisation au départ le départ
s'accentue les aînés la mutation est en
réalité a provoqué un surplus ne supplée
de dépenses n'assure plus dépenses parce
que les surplus de personnel après de la
bonne façon de régionalisation l'allée
verte de la régionalisation a coûté plus
cher que c'est exactement le même
mécanisme donc là en revenant à des
gestions qui sont plus normal en tout
cas plus en adéquation avec la politique
de leur territoire ils ont réussi à
faire l'effort qui était demandée et
pour cela on doit les féliciter
alors il ya un problème un peu politique
aussi effaré même démocratique qui se
pose c'est où fo le celui delà du
contrôle par les citoyens des dépenses
des maires des portes de leurs élus est
ce que si justement si on les prive de
cette taxe d'habitation vous le disiez
ils ont au début ils ont dit mais alors
comment les citoyens
quelle va être notre nos rapports avec
nos administrés est ce que les contrôles
de contrôle par les citoyens aussi
simple qu'il pouvait l'être avec un taxe
d'habitation par exemple je sais pas
s'il compte
par les citoyens via la taxe
d'habitation sais pas si t'es pas
vraiment clair parce que franchement je
serais curieux de savoir quel citoyen
comprend exactement proche de celle axe
d'habitation qui paye et à quoi il sert
je pense qu'il faut qu'on change un
petit peu de paradigme dans notre
relation justement aux citoyens et ça
commence dès l'échelon local
c'est elle qui a pas deux il n'y a pas
de honte à montrer le budget de la
municipalité les dépenses qu'on engage
et les investissements qu'on fait je
pense qu'il faut être assez clair ce
niveau là est assez transparent avec
l'historien ils peuvent le comprendre
par exemple moi je sais et ça se fait ça
se fait en général de façon systématique
quand un nouvel élu arrive dans une
mairie quand il vient d'être élu qui l'a
battu un sortant et c'est la première
des choses qu'il fait en général et
lucette demandé un audit financé et de
simplement savoir
oui oui il en est où il en est de la
situation financière je pense que cet
audit financier quand ils le font ils
ont tout intérêt à le rendre public tout
intérêt de rendre publics a expliqué aux
citoyens je pense que pour avoir une
meilleure lisibilité de l'action de la
municipalité en dehors des choses qu'on
voit sortir des maisons santé une école
qui rénovait une église qui est rénovée
de
un marché qu'on a vu qu'on invente des
commerçants qui se met en place à tout
ça c'est des réalisations convoi parce
que on les voit de nos yeux mais il faut
aller plus loin dans l'explication
citoyens et travailler plus avec je
pense que les gens l'ont exprimé la
crise des gilet jaune mais oui même
avant même avant je pense que l'élection
d' emmanuel macron n'est pas étrangère
non plus à une certaine appétence pour
les gens sans pour autant s'engager sur
des listes municipales législatives et
autres mais une appétence pour les gens
à la vie de la cité a participé à vis la
cité au sens grec du terme dans le sens
noble du terme
donc il faut qu'on accompagne un citoyen
là dedans en travaillant de plus en plus
avec eux en étant de plus en plus
transparent avec eux et et a essayé de
faire comprendre ce qu'est aussi c'est
absolument goûter qui est passé est
assez complexe
il ya une autre question qui est aussi
une question aux démocratique et marié
des gilet jaune c'était une question que
ça petit et que pose le problème des
finances locales c'est celui de la
cohésion nationale la cohésion des
territoires au fond parce qu'il ya une
forte inégalité dans les revenus des
communes dans les revenus même d'aider
des collectivités locales des
départements aussi
et est ce que le rôle de l'état aussi
essaie de compenser les inégalités là il
ya deux choses il ya la dotation globale
de fonctionnement que l'état vote qui
est stable depuis 2010 est on vous la
dire ni 2017 on a gardé le niveau 2017
et qui n'a pas bougé et après il ya un
mécanisme excessivement compliqué qu'ils
fassent par le comité des finances
locales qui est gérée par des élus là
l'état n'est plus pour rien l'état donne
une somme globale nationale après le
comité des finances locales lui fait la
péréquation la distribution jusqu'à la
commune comme une langue commune et là
effectivement il ya un je ne sais plus
quand même critère je crois qu'il n'a
pas loin de quarante deux critères pour
pour pour faire ce calcul a c'est très
compliqué je crois que plus personne n'y
comprend rien un jour ou l'autre il va
falloir qu'on revoie un petit peu ce
calcul à personne n'ose aujourd'hui le
maître parce que c'est très très
compliqué entre les péréquations etc
quand j'entends beaucoup de maires
ruraux et je les entends gelé compliqué
que d'essayer ray bien qu'ils râlent en
disant ben voila moi j'ai plus rien
alors
j'en ai marre de payer moi je fais une
gestion saine de mai municipalité de ma
commune et je paye pour ceux qui
dépensent l'argent sans compter c'est
pas aussi simple que ça les a bien gérés
application ce n'est pas que ça mais je
pense qu'il va falloir là dans la
réforme de la fiscalité locale qu'on met
en place on veut déjà plus de visibilité
pour les citoyens et plus de visibilité
pour le bloc communal aussi pour qu'ils
sachent exactement à quoi s'attendre
c'est pour ça qu'on le discute au niveau
de la loi de finances 2020 pour une
application qui sera en 2021
donc on continue les discussions avec
les associations d'élus pour atterrir
sur quelque chose qui semble cohérent et
lisible par tous le coup de la part de
tva je passais vous rappelez matrice
monsieur quand on l'a fait pour les
régions les régions ont râlé au début
nous parce qu'évidemment partait un peu
dans l'inconnu une part de tva
ok on va compenser sa est la même
dotation mais si la tva b enfin si les
recettes de tva baisse mais sauf que
c'est un impôt ultra dynamique et que
quand ils montent ils vont beaucoup plus
vite qu'ils ne baissent il donc les
départements qui craignent de perdre
finalement une manne financière parce
que c'est un auteur de 14,1 milliards
d'euros qu'on doit compenser pour les
départements finalement vont récupérer
cette part de tva qui va encore être
dynamique dans les années qui suivent
ils ont au final plus d'argent que ce
qu'ils avaient avant il faut qu'ils
comprennent donc les les relations entre
les élus les maires notamment et la
majorité le gouvernement sont à votre
avis en train de s'apaiser
c'est encore compliqué passé losc et
c'est compliqué parce que vous annoncer
des mesures c'est comme mon amour un
faut des preuves avec l'épreuve
voilà y'a que les preuves donc au fur et
à mesure que ça va se mettre en place
bien évidemment les gens vont comprendre
les maires faut pas qu'ils s'inquiètent
parce que cette ce taux de fiscalité sur
lequel il pouvait jouer avec les th
ils pourront le faire avec la taxe
foncière même si aujourd'hui ils en sont
pas passionnés mais il ya que
l'application de ce qu'on met en place
qui prouvera qu'effectivement c'est
efficace
on sait qu'à moyen terme en tout cas il
faut espérer que dans les deux années
qui viennent où il est c'est à dire les
choses soient claires et elles
s'améliorent
alors j'ai dit vous êtes des députés
modem et il ya peut-être on peut
peut-être abordé deux ou trois sujets
d'actualité qui est qu'ils sont
importants aujourd'hui on voir rejaillir
par exemple le débat sur le voile
qu'est ce qu'elle est quelle est votre
position là dessus
moi je pense notamment à la hors de
l'école les promenades honnête des
enfants et je pense qu'il faut pas faire
de surenchère il faut pas faire de
stigmatisation faut nommer les choses
faut pas avoir peur de les nommer on a
un problème de radicalisation c'est vrai
islamique
alors je rappelle en plus que l'islam
radical n'est pas là n'est pas de
religion c'est une idéologie il faut
quand même bien joué et ça en tête c'est
la première chose et deuxième chose
la loi existe aujourd'hui faisons-le à
appliquer mais bon une femme voilée dès
l'instant où son visage est pas caché
moi personnellement surtout que là on
vous fait référence à l'incident qui a
eu lieu au conseil régional arryadia la
sinne au conseil régional il ya le betis
de l'éducation qui dit que
personnellement il n'est pas très
favorable ce que des femmes voilées non
mais je comprends mais alors de deux
choses l'une de deux choses l'une
puisqu'on parle des sorties scolaires où
on enlève tous les signes ostentatoires
religieux quel qu'il soit la croix pour
les catholiques la benauge ritz a
annoncé pas hypocrite c'est la télé risi
d'un site de la laïcité où on enlève
tous les signes visibles pour tous et
moi j'ai pas de souci là-dessus je pas
de souci ou alors si on les autorise
dans l'espace public à concurrence pour
le voile justement que les femmes ne
soient pas intégralement voilées et
qu'on puisse voir leurs visages et à ce
moment là ça ne me gêne pas dès
l'instant où il n'ya pas de prosélytisme
qui est fait dehors en sortie scolaire
on s'aperçoit page
voilà c'est juste sa bague pour moi ya
pas de problème c'est un faux débat on
politise la chose parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'on aime politiser cette
chose là mais si on regardait simplement
la loi rien que la loi on aurait de quoi
déjà appliqué les choses comme il faut
vous n'avez pas l'impression quand même
qu'on est dans un moment de la société
où les les problèmes sont très exacerbée
où les tensions sont très vives sur tous
les sujets moi je trouve assez
paradoxalement
que si on regarde les vingt dernières
années par exemple où les 50 dernières
années on peut même aller là les
minorités s'exprimer parce qu'elle avait
besoin d'exister simplement qu'on les
reconnaisse on a eu toute cette phase là
et maintenant les minorités veulent
imposer leur loi
parce que elles sont persuadées d'être
détentrice du bien pour le reste du
monde
mais donc aux blessés les lois des
minorités devenir loi générale chez le
oui mais mais sauf que ça ne marche pas
comme ça va dépendre à saint lô qu'une
minorité ne peut imposer ses vues à tout
le monde et la liberté de chacun elle
doit être respectée
et effectivement on devient là il ya
plus beaucoup de médiation on le voit on
avec des associations vegan avec des
associations même environnemental on a
vu
l'extinction rébellion je suis désolé 7
juin voilà tout toutes ces
manifestations qui sont basés sur le
déni de l'autre sur la haine une
certaine violence et une certaine
violence et il faut qu'on les combattent
absolument parce qu'il en va de l'avenir
de la démocratie au fait merci
infiniment leur dire merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]